so Marvel Studios and Sony are moving
forward very quickly with their
Spider-Man 4 plans and not just
Spider-Man 4 but the future plans of
Spider-Man in general as we have a
synopsis for Spider-Man 4 today and
reports stating that Spider-Man is
already going to be a leader in
Spider-Man 4 we also hear that Daredevil
and maybe Ant-Man are going to be a part
of Spider-Man 4 as well and some people
really don't like this I've seen a lot
of people talking about it on line
because the ending of Spider-Man no way
home finally set up Peter Parker to be
on his own to be that friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man that we know and
love from the comics but with these new
reports about Spider-Man 4 today they
state that he's already a leader so
perhaps some time has passed in the MCU
since we've seen him last which I
understand how it could hit people the
wrong way but today we're going to go
over everything that has been said
recently about Spider-Man 4 including
the synopsis that is out there right now
and the fact that this could be another
civil war movie mov but not exactly how
you think not with the characters that
you would think so let's dive into it
but if you're new be sure to subscribe
to the channel so you can stay up to
date on all Spider-Man news and MCU news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
down below you are automatically entered
in our giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items and some DC items as well the
winner picks one item and we pick one
winner at the end of each month so some
major details about Spider-Man 4 have
been put out there in a synopsis by two
really credible insiders Alex Perez from
the COS circus.com and cryptic HD
quality and they confirm a huge plot of
this movie Alex Perez put this out there
as the synopsis and plot of the movie
stating Kingpin as the mayor of NYC puts
into effect a law that Outlaws
vigilantism targeting Heroes like
Spider-Man and Daredevil among others
and establishes a bounty hunt for these
Heroes where several villains pop in for
their shot at taking down Spidey and
Daredevil sign me up The Insider cryptic
HD quality backed this up as well but
added a little bit more stating that
Spider-Man 4 will have the Civil War
layout but street level any Avengers
will be minor unclear what role any of
them including Ant-Man would play
Spider-Man is already a leader and
Spider-Man 4 and is essential to the
mcu's Future now there's a lot to break
down here and I believe I know how it's
all going to kind of play out but first
let's address the Ant-Man showing up in
Spider-Man for rumor this is a report
which originally came from Daniel rpk
and the report originally said that
Marvel Studios is looking for another
big name to put in Spider-Man 4 much
like they did with Robert dowy Jr with
happy Hogan with the other two
Spider-Man basically Sony and Marvel are
looking for another person to kind of
Mentor Peter Parker which is something
that not a lot of people want it's not
that they don't want cameos in the movie
it's that we don't want Peter Parker to
have a mentor and somebody looking out
for him we want him to finally be on on
his own I actually have a lot of
thoughts about this and I'll share them
in another video so look out for that
but I will say Ant-Man showing up in
Spider-Man 4 does make sense if you
think about it the future of Marvel
Studios is Spider-Man right now he's
probably the biggest face in the MCU
right now yes we do have people like
doctor strange and the Scarlet Witch and
of course Sam Wilson is Captain America
now but none of them are really the
leader of the Avengers even Ant-Man has
never been in a leadership role but of
of course now all our leaders are gone
Captain America's gone Iron Man's gone
the Scarlet Witch Hulk has kind of been
nerfed you get it and yes we have heard
the reports stating that Spider-Man is
going to be the lead character in King
Dynasty and Secret Wars not necessarily
the leader of the Avengers but the lead
character of The Movies that's why it
makes sense to have Ant-Man come into
Spider-Man 4 because the last thing that
Ant-Man did was deal with Kang and
that's not something that you just keep
to yourself I know the ending of Ant-Man
on the wasp PTO Mania kind of played it
off like Ant-Man believed everything was
okay but if you face somebody like King
the Conqueror a multiversal villain
somebody who has already killed many
different Avengers before and somebody
who has blatantly stated that there are
other variants of himself out there you
need to tell somebody and he's had
run-ins with Sam Wilson before however
we have no idea what is going to take
place in Captain America 4 I'm betting
that out of everybody that Ant-Man would
want to go and tell about King he would
probably search for dror strange in New
York I think Spider-Man would definitely
be on his mind but I think Doctor
Strange would be his first pick however
Doctor Strange during this time is
probably not going to be in our
Dimension he's probably going to be with
Clea helping reverse an incursion that
he caused which we saw in the post
credit for Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness so he could go to
New York search for Doctor Strange finds
out from maybe Wong or somebody else
that he can find Doctor Strange so he
decides to look for Spider-Man I'm sure
he might mention it to Wong as well or
maybe Wong is also gone on and that's
why he looks for Peter and I think this
is how Ant-Man could get involved in
Spider-Man 4 and this makes sense it's
not just doing a cameo for Cameo sake
however I really hope they don't make
him the mentor and I don't think Ant-Man
would really stand in a position to be
the type of Mentor that Tony Stark was
to him or happy Hogan was to him I think
he would be more like of a colleague to
him which is why I'm okay with Daredevil
being in this movie as well Daredevil
would be a mentor to him and would
definitely help him out but again I
don't think it would be like Tony Stark
was Tony Stark was basically like a
father to Peter and happy Hogan
basically tried to fill that role for
him when Tony was gone as well and let's
face it Nick Fury was kind of like a
babysitter to Peter he kind of just told
him what to do and it wasn't even really
Fury and far from home so that's not how
it would be with Daredevil or Ant-Man
they would be more like colleagues and I
think it would be really cool to see
them all together especially the bug
Bros now according to cryptic HD quality
we are going to see other characters
like Kate Jessica and Ekko appear along
with others that they don't want to
mention yet but they did state that this
is kind of going to be like a little
Civil War on a street level and that is
going to be because of the law that
Kingpin establishes as the mayor the one
that Outlaws vigilantism so it's
basically going to be like a mini
Captain America Civil War the premise is
almost pretty much the same instead of
the sovia Accords they have this new law
placed by Kingpin so I'm sure some
people are going to want to follow the
law and not be Vigilantes anymore but
some people are going to think that it's
dumb and they're going to do it anyways
it looks like Spider-Man is going to get
caught somewhat in the middle and we
could see some Defenders like Jessica
Jones returning which has been reported
and then maybe some characters like
Ant-Man might have a different
perspective because he has a daughter in
a family but then on the other hand it
looks like Daredevil has been fighting
crime for a while now and probably
doesn't plan to give it up anytime soon
so this is where kind of the Civil War
could come in a debate between all of
the Vigilantes about whether to continue
or not now I do like this as far as the
story goes I like how grounded and
street level it could be however I do
think by the end they ultimately are
going to set up something way bigger
because of course this movie is going to
go into King Dynasty and Secret Wars so
I think by the end of this movie the
threat of Kang is going to be very very
real whether that is brought on by
Ant-Man or by a variant appearing or
incursion starting to happen I think
it's going to become very apparent that
Kang is possibly about to destroy their
universe and take over the entire
Multiverse since Spider-Man is going to
be the lead of the next two Avengers
films they have to set this up now they
could do it in a post credit scene
however I think it probably would need a
little bit more time to be set up so I
think the movie is going to end with
whoever the main villain of this film is
going to be is going to be defeated I
don't think it's going to be Kingpin I
do think that they are eventually going
to do an actual Sinister 6 movie in the
MCU with Tom Holland Spider-Man and
Kingpin will be a part of that and he's
obviously going to play a pretty big
role in Spider-Man 4 but I don't think
he'll be the main villain I don't think
Spider-Man is the feeding Kingpin in
this movie so what will most likely
happen is that whoever they deem to be
the main villain of this will be
defeated by Spider-Man then they'll talk
about how the real person in charge that
needs to be defeated is Kingpin they'll
kind of end it there and then go into
whatever they need to go into to set up
King Dynasty and Secret Wars and
honestly if that's what this next
Spider-Man movie is about I'm here for
it Spider-Man with Daredevil with
Ant-Man that's going to be really really
cool especially if they are simply kind
of his colleagues his buddies people who
are looking after him because he's also
looking after them just like friends do
but not like a father figure like Tony
Stark happy Hogan or Nick Fury we need
Spider-Man to be on his own and like I
said I'll do another video about that
but in the meantime let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below do you like the
premise for Spider-Man 4 with Daredevil
Ant-Man and others possibly showing up
in the film or do you want to see it go
in a different direction let us know
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe you can stay up to date on the
latest news you can find us on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof
woof